et l'astronaute prend le contrôle du
sous-marin
pour une première fois quelle sensation
thomaster les gros avions en fait c'est
un peu les mêmes les mêmes anticipations
les mêmes effets d'inertie il faut
donner une situation franche une bonne
anticipation plutôt que mettre des
petits coups de 5 degrés en permanence
mais bon après ça c'est le métier qui
rentre
un insignonneur que les Françaises et
les Français m'ont fait à deux reprises
et donc ça mobilité
je pose la question certains vous avez
lu la presse en sont inquiétés on se
disait peut-être y avait-il du
flottement
qui a été beaucoup utilisé si vous
n'êtes plus Jupiter vous êtes devenu qui
alors après
cette comparaison mythologie bonjour
bonjour
vous voulez être maire de Rome
habillé en Néron oui
[Rires]
mais Néron enfin je sais pas je suis pas
très très beau en Histoire romaine
il a fait tuer sa mère il est exécuté
des chrétiens c'est ça c'est votre
programme une nouvelle équipe de grandes
gueules composées aujourd'hui de Bruno
Pommard l'ex policier du raid et mère
toujours oui toujours salut Alain et
puis je suis Olivier moi ça commence
de policiers qui ont sauvé un gosse des
quartiers en lui faisant des massages
cardiaques formidable on en a pas
beaucoup parlé mais il faut le signaler
ça s'appelle c'est Valérie et
moi il y a plein de choses que
j'aimerais brûler la bureaucratie par
exemple je brûlerai tout ce qui ne va
pas
non mais en réalité on est très
pacifique
on est très calme on veut résoudre les
problèmes dans le respect de la
démocratie avec simplicité et bonté
une minute sur RMC RMC jusqu'à 9 heures
Apolline matin
[Musique]
vous gagnez 20000 euros quel est votre
projet je m'achète des chaussures sur
mesure parce que je
du 33 34
j'aimerais bien avoir des escarpins un
jour des chaussures plus adulte avec une
taille enfant ça n'existe pas très peu
en fait c'est difficile à trouver et
après toute cette agitation quoi de
mieux qu'un bon moment de détente dans
l'herbe
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président de nous
avoir accordé cette entretien merci à
vous merci
je souhaite que dans cette journée
j'achète un bon 14 juillet à tous nos
compatriotes mais ayez l'espoir et cette
volonté de à la fois d'ambition et de
respect de chacun c'est ça qui nous unit
qui nous rend plus fort nous allons y
arriver merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]